Between Netflix, Amazon, cable networks, and
every other way to watch T.V. these days,
there's a real wealth of great stories out
there for fantasy fans — many of which have
been on the air for some time.
So whether you're looking for fairies, witches,
or ancient gods, here are the best fantasy
shows that you still might not be watching.
Amazon has made a few splashy entries into
the fantasy genre over the last few years,
but Carnival Row might be their most ambitious
project yet.
Based on a film script by showrunner Travis
Beacham, the show tells the story of a mythical
world where a group of supernatural creatures
called "fae" are forced to integrate into
human society after war strikes their community.
Naturally, this creates plenty of discord
between the two populations, especially considering
that humans are immediately distrustful of
this group of powerful, magical beings.
Of course, it also doesn't help that there's
a supernatural serial killer running around,
either.
The show is packed with plenty of star power,
including Orlando Bloom, Cara Delevingne,
and Jared Harris.
So if you're looking for a series that beautifully
blends magic with mystery and murder, then
you might just want to take a stroll down
Carnival Row.
Time travel is always a great conceit for
any fantasy show, since it allows characters
to freely travel across all kinds of different
worlds and eras, and Starz' hit series Outlander
uses this device to perfect effect.
Based on Diana Gabaldon's book series, this
adaptation stars Caitriona Balfe as Claire
Randall, a married nurse who's just survived
World War II, only to find herself transported
back to Scotland in 1743 by a set of magical
stones.
Trapped in a time where women have no rights
or any autonomy, Claire tries to find her
way back home — but soon falls for Jamie
Fraser, a Highlander she marries for protection.
As their bond deepens, Claire begins to resist
the chance to return home, eventually trying
to manipulate time itself to keep the two
lovers together.
Thanks to its steamy central romance, captivating
characters, and exciting story, the show has
been a huge success for Starz, serving as
one of the cable network's biggest hits and
earning rave reviews from critics since it
premiered in 2014.
So if you're looking for romance, adventure,
and attractive people with British accents,
then don't worry — Claire and Jamie have
got you covered.
As one of the most popular American novelists
of today, Neil Gaiman's work is always ripe
for adaptation, and in 2019, Amazon became
the official home of Good Omens, a show based
on Gaiman's groundbreaking collaboration with
the legendary Terry Pratchett.
It's the story of an angel named Aziraphale
and a demon called Crowley, who must work
together to stop the impending apocalypse
— as they've gotten pretty comfortable inhabiting
their human bodies on Earth.
Ultimately, this show has everything fantasy
fans could possibly want, bringing its religious
elements and ethereal action into play in
a quirky, whimsical way that thrives on the
chemistry between David Tennant and Michael
Sheen.
Good Omens was an immediate hit when it premiered
on Amazon Prime in May 2019, with critics
praising its humor in particular.
With just six episodes, now is as good a time
as ever to binge this quick, funny series
that balances light humor with the heaviest
of stakes.
“To the world."
"To the world."
As Good Omens has shown, Neil Gaiman adaptations
have proven to be pretty fertile television
ground over the past couple of years — but
perhaps the biggest and boldest of any Gaiman
TV show is American Gods, based on his 2001
novel of the same name.
The show follows the saga of Shadow Moon,
an ex-convict who's drawn into a conflict
between the new and old gods.
And as he encounters leprechauns, hammer-wielding
deities, and the personification of the media,
he's shepherded along by Mr. Wednesday, a
charming yet mysterious con man who sits right
in the heart of this pan-religious war.
"When you strike lightning you should expect
consequences."
With a knockout cast and a rock solid story,
it's no wonder that American Gods has been
a hit since its 2017 premiere.
Ever since Riverdale burst onto the scene
in 2017, becoming one of the most talked about
shows on television, it's been clear that,
somehow, Archie comics still offer a deep
well of material to pull from.
Once Riverdale proved it was a bona fide sensation,
showrunner Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa teamed up
with Netflix to develop The Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina, based on another Archie comic.
Starring Mad Men's very own Kiernan Shipka,
the show takes on a much darker tone than
you might remember from the lighter Melissa
Joan Hart Sabrina series.
As a half-witch, this new Sabrina Spellman
is constantly struggling to find a bridge
between her two worlds.
Putting Sabrina's fantastical identity crisis
at the forefront and mixing that with romance,
intrigue, action, and horror has proven incredibly
successful for this fledgling show, and thanks
in large part to Shipka's grounding performance,
the series has received glowing reviews.
The first adaptation of Deborah Harkness'
wildly popular All Souls trilogy of novels,
UK series A Discovery of Witches premiered
with an eight episode season in September
2018, delighting Harkness fans and newbies
alike.
Initially set at Oxford University, the series
chronicles the journeys and adventures of
Diana Bishop: a historian trying to deny her
true identity as a witch, who comes across
a haunted tome in the university's library
and finds herself swept into a world of magic
and monsters.
With the help of a vampire-scientist named
Matthew Clairmont, Diana must embrace her
heritage and fight her prejudice against vampires
as they team up to not only protect the book,
but explore its mysteries to the fullest.
Though Warner Brothers initially acquired
the rights to A Discovery of Witches for a
film adaptation, the UK network Sky One eventually
bought the rights, turning it into a series
of their own.
And that seems to have been a pretty smart
move on their part, as the show currently
has a 100 percent approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes.
If you're not in the UK, you can check out
the show on both AMC and BBC America.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.